hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wonderful game from the now
semi-finals of the fiji grand prix it's
uh i'm in tabatabai versus wesley so and
it's a game that really shows you how
one move makes all the difference it's a
weird thing to say in chess because of
course it's a game you know where each
player makes a move so of course one
move will make a difference but uh here
uh it's you know it's hard to emphasize
how much of a difference it makes but
you'll see what i mean by this it's
really an enjoyable one now let's dive
straight into it so amin opens up with
uh d4 we have knight to f6 and before we
continue uh it's important to mention
that wesley won his game with the y
pieces so this is the return game the
second game of their match and now i
mean needs to win in order to force uh
uh rapid tie breaks uh so that being
said let's continue uh we have c4 uh e6
knight to c3 and uh bishop to b4 wesley
goes for the names of indian defense
knight to f3 and now wesley castles and
here we have a3 all right we said that
this was uh sort of a sort of an older
way to do this where you actually uh
allow black to double your pawns here
after capturing the knight but uh lately
everyone's been playing this instead of
the queen c2 line and it's been going
very well for for white so why not
bishop captures on c3 b captures and now
c5 offering white to triple his pawns
but of course
we are not interested in that uh here i
mean just continues developing we have
pawn to g3 preparing to fiance to the
light square bishop and wesley does the
same uh he wants to counter white's
strong light square bishop on this
diagonal so here bishop g2 bishop to b7
and now uh d5
and it is now already as of move 9 that
we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how wesley deals with this he
pushes a d6 uh leaving the option of
advancing the pawn to e5 at any moment
and here we have castles uh we have
queen the e7 uh and here uh you could go
e4 right away but i mean goes knight to
h4 yeah he's saying that if you ever
capture on d5 or push this one to e5 you
are losing control over the f5 square
and then i'm to put my knight on f5 so
wesley says all right now i'm not going
to do that knight b to d7 uh wasteland
continues development and rook to e1
preparing for that e4 push and now comes
knight to e5 and this is now a beautiful
square for the knight because if you
don't push f4 it's very unlikely that
you are getting rid of it uh and well
maybe f4 would be a bit too aggressive
of course you would enjoy having the
spawn chain uh but uh
opening up your king like this might it
might be a bit too soon for this so here
your c4 pawn is the attack and how do
you defend it
uh the problem is you could only defend
it with a move like queen to b3
but what is your queen doing on b3 it's
really a silly square for the queen and
there's really nothing to do on the
queen side so here we have e4
sacrificing the c for pawn knight
captures on c4 and now bishop back to f1
so uh you see that black's plan that was
successful here wesley was able to first
create a double c pawn and then attack
one of them as they are very easy
targets uh but this was maybe white's
plan all along so bishop to f1 and not
knight to e5
interestingly if this if wesley did not
only need the draw here maybe he would
go for b5 here and go for a very very
sharp game but as he only needs a draw i
imagine that's why he went back knight
to the e5 and now c4 now we don't have a
double c pawn and uh by giving up this
one pawn we've opened up this diagonal
for our light square bishop so this is
uh
uh well i i don't see who wouldn't go
for this now when you actually see
what's happening when the pawn was on c3
it's very hard to develop your light
square bishop here after the pawn is
gone you get this diagonal and everyone
would give up this pawn so here knight
g6 offering a trade of knights and
knight back to g2 and now only now we
have b5 uh yes the b5 pawn is undefended
but you are weakening white's d5 pawn
and that's all that matters so here c
captures on b5 wesley now trades e
captures on the e5 and e captures on the
e5 and you can't go for the d5 pawn yet
because your queen is hanging so queen
d7 by wesley and now knight to e3 we are
keeping an eye on that the d5 pawn
uh rook after e8 this is played with a
with an idea of actually winning the d5
pawn uh as you'll see so bishop to b2
finally we grab hold of this long
diagonal and now knight captures on d5
looks very scary because well white is
defending the d5 square twice but not
really because rook captures on e1 it
was the plan all along so knight
captures on the e5 and now we play rook
captures on e1 and this is the moment
where things get extremely interesting
and i will just show you one line uh
that doesn't work but it's very
important for the continuation of the
game here you're you you could choose
the capture on e1 but you could also
choose to maybe play knight to f6 check
first because you know that after the
queen captures rook black will pick up
the knight on d5 so why not mess up the
black spawn structure by playing knight
to f6 first
the reason is after knight to f6 check
of course black will capture as there's
a royal fork happening queen captures an
e1 now knights to h4 is just winning for
wesley that's the problem uh the queen
on e1 is in a terrible spot knight to f3
check is the thread of a royal fork
and there just isn't a good move of
course you can't capture the knight
because queen g4 check and that's it
you're getting checkmated bishop g2 this
will be checkmate so what you could do
is maybe play queen e3 that uh
avoided the
the scary fork but still knight f3
checking h1 and now all of the nasty
discoveries are possible you can even
bring a rook into the game to improve
your position further and this will be
completely unplayable black is
completely winning here so uh having
that in mind we go into the line that
actually works for black and that is uh
or rather for white queen captures on e1
uh and the bishop captures on d5 so as
we've discussed and now comes rook to d1
it's always this miraculous rook a to d1
move that brings so much to the game uh
always you know
anderson's immortal game comes to mind
or rather his evergreen game whenever
rook a31 was played uh but here uh it's
uh completely different but it brings so
much to the game uh so what is the rook
actually doing on d1 okay it's attacking
the bishop uh but more importantly it's
actually preventing wesley from going
for the force line that we've just
discussed uh from going knight to h4
here you could play bishop back to e6
you could play queen to e6 the guard the
bishop but wesley actually goes for
knight to h4 and it seems like it should
be working or rather that wesley can
force a draw and because wesley won the
first game uh drawing the second one
means that he wins the the semi-final
match the problem is uh there is one
move here that prevents wesley from
not just the drawing the game but also
from escaping uh with uh with with his
you know head intact uh so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
move that wins the game for white while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on supporting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is uh
rook to d3 that's the good stuff and
before we continue uh we first have to
ask ourselves what happens if rook
captures on d5 and what happens if g
captures an h4 because we
we already showed the pre
the line previously we know that this
doesn't work due to queen g4 check and
after visual blocks you get checkmated
uh but what about uh rook captures on d5
well again just knight f3 check and
there's a royal fork happening king h1
knight captures we lose the queen
the problem for black is here or rather
for wesley after rook to d3 there just
isn't a move black can play
because now with the f3 square covered
uh
that's that's a pretty big deal and now
if knight to f3 check okay you might
think it's a royal fork so i might not
win a queen but he will have to give up
the rook the problem is after rook
captures on f3 and bishop captures we
have this queen c3 attacking the bishop
and threatening checkmate and there's
just no way out of this okay you could
play queen g4 now you guard the the g7
square and the bishop here but now comes
the mighty h3 pawn and black can just
resign here you have to move the queen
you can't keep an eye on the bishop and
on the g7 square so it's better to
defend against checkmate now we just
pick up the bishop and now of course
white
white is completely winning there's no
way there's just no way out of this
uh so uh what else could you play after
this rook to d3 move so knight to f3
doesn't work could we maybe just move
the bishop back why shouldn't this be
possible we already know that the pawn
cannot capture the knight because of
this check well now even that changed
with the rook coming to d3 now after the
knight is captured queen g4 check we can
block rook g3 and not only uh do you uh
say uh save yourself from getting
checkmated you are also just winning the
game on the spot after the queen moves
so not available for wesley and now i
want now that you see what happens after
rook to d3 now all of a sudden both the
bishop and the knight are hanging so
what can westley play uh queen g4
that's a that's a brilliant resource by
wesley so he of course finds the
absolute best way to continue uh now the
point is uh okay well what happens if we
capture the
uh the the welding of course knight to
f3 will win the game for black but what
can we play here uh bishop to e2 here
attacking the queen and what can
where can the queen go uh well that's
one way to do it but uh we don't we
don't want to do it first we play queen
to c3 uh we threaten the g7 pawn and
still knight is hanging bishop is
hanging and the queen has to keep an eye
on the g7 square and now if you go
knight to f3 and it seems like it should
be working still just rook captures
bishop captures and now again the mighty
h3 move uh forces the queen away either
from the defense of the bishop or the g7
square so after queen to c3 wesley says
all right bishop to e4 and now it seems
that wesley saved both the knight and
the bishop the problem is the resulting
end game is just uh
lost for him because now bishop to e2
and of course uh
uh bishop uh cannot be captured as
checkmate is still being threatened so
queen g5 we have to keep an eye on g7
and now rook captures and e6 and now
white's position is just winning even
though the material is completely even
knight to f5 wesley brings the knight
back into the game which tempo the rook
is attacked queen e5 now pinning the
knight the knight cannot move we have
queen to e7 offering a queen trade and
the wesley uh wesley offers a queen
trade and i mean happily trades with not
a queen captures knight captures and
here pawn to a4 and he was in this
position on move 30 that wesley saw
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it seems like there
should be because the material is
completely equal
but uh the uh well
if you look at it more closely white has
two two points on the queen side black
only has one so you know that white is
creating a pass pawn very very soon
another thing is there's no way for
black to actually activate the rook with
white controlling this um
d8 square so it's uh you know a
beautiful open d file the rook might
come to d7 you might put more pressure
on the position bishop is coming to see
for you have a bishop here controlling
this diagonal it's a fully open board uh
with i mean having the bishop fare but i
know you guys really enjoyed when i uh
sort of finished game so let's see what
happens if let's say rook to e8 okay you
could claim the other open file now
bishop c4 and now after let's say bishop
to f5 you want to guard against rook to
d7 uh now we push a5 we want to create a
pass pawn and after creating some
breeding room for the black king now we
play f3 we're going to play knight to g6
uh now the rook is controlling the the
open e file but not just b6 and after
captures and captures there's just no
way of actually stopping the pawn you
could play rook to b8 but still just
bishop to a6 now we're getting our pawn
to b7 after something like king f8 you
want to get your king into the game
uh b7 is played and black is really
without moves if you try king to a7 or
something like that we can even play
something like rook captures on g6 and
after bishop captures bishop to e5 and
that's it black can no longer no longer
drag this on so of course wesley knows
this and after this a4 he resigns
without pushing this any further and
incredibly uh he he he completely
dominated the game uh in the previous
game where he had the white pieces but
here after this rook to d1 the knight to
h4 idea simply doesn't work and here
probably wesley just wanted to draw this
uh he already won the first game and it
means that he gets to the finals of the
of the grand prix which means that he uh
uh
well uh reached the pinnacle of the
tournament uh but uh knight stage four
just doesn't work after rookie to d1 and
it's a it's a dangerous mindset always
to be having i don't know if wesley was
playing this uh because he really wanted
to force a draw uh
probably i don't know it's hard to say
but of course if you if you spot this
then you look for some other moves and
then you find the
moves like just moving the bishop or
moving the queen but here incredible how
the inclusion of rook 8 to d1 prevents
all of these threats that were possible
while the file was unoccupied by any of
white's rooks
so
brilliant brilliant stuff by i mean who
who successfully forces a tie break
we'll see what happens in the tie break
uh so hope you guys really enjoyed this
and hope that you were able to solve
this rook to d3 mystery as it's one of
the nicer ones that we've had in a while
uh i would like to thank pascal poirer
uh mladin jurich
showtime and irobic for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
grand prix until it ends so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day